Ah... La maladie on aime bien, hein ?
Les amis aujourd'hui je suis malade et très fatigué
car j'ai très mal dormi car je suis malade j'vous l'avais dit
Le mec qu'arrive à être lourd à la quatrième seconde de sa vidéo c'est quand même fantastique c'est un record .
Aujourd'hui on va tester notre cerveau
Vous savez que j'aime bien mettre à l'épreuve le cerveau humain
Le rendre dépourvu de tout sens
*malaise*
quand je suis malade j'arrive pas à faire de belles phrases c'est comme ça
et bien aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé un site qui s'apelle
Human Benchmark.com , qu'est-ce qu'un benchmark ?
les gros geeks -sa mère- le savent très bien
c'est quelque chose qui teste les performances
d'un objet donné ou d'un logiciel ou voilà
par exemple t'as les benchmark pour  les cartes graphiques
ça permet de les comparer entre elles pour les processeurs etc
nous on va comparer entre nous nos cerveaux
qui a le plus de matière grise hein
donc je le fais avec la maladie on verra si mon cerveau
garde cette puissance légendaire ou si du coup
il est en extinction total
ce test est composé de quatre étapes bien distinctes
les unes des autres
un peu comme les tests de QI
finalement tu as le test où il faut retenir des chiffres
des épreuves de temps de réactions -c'est bien ça !-
des épreuves où il faut retenir des verbes
et des épreuves ça teste la mémoire visuelle
vous savez on a la mémoire visuelle, auditive et aussi la mémoire des mouvements
et ça je savais pas, c'est vous qui me l'aviez appris
parce que voilà Youtube finalement c'est quoi ?
c'est le partage
BON ALORS !
Number Memory test
Les personnes normales peuvent retenir sept nombres à la fois
quel est le plus grand nombre que tu peux mémoriser ?
ah ouais donc ils veulent vraiment que ma vidéo soit ennuyante
genre je vais vraiment devoir me concentrer et pas parler
Allez start c'est parti
Ah ça va vite !
-putain-
7, Level 1  passé
Excellent
7777 hmp-ffff-
j'ai chatté là ?
t'sais le testeuh... genre tout le monde
est sur un pied d'égalité mais pas trop non plus
j'ai carrément chatté
Level 4,  73139 allez vas-y suivant suivant là
c'est bon j'ai vu -putain- *tape sur son bureau* ça m'ééééénèèèèèèèèrve
73139 suivant
634932 allez go 634932
là ça commence à être dur je vais devoir
commencer à ne plus parler - du coup-
si je suis réussis celui-là je suis dans la moyenne
1987369
Oh putain je suis dans la moyenne
je me sens exceptionnel
489828274
Excellent!
C'est excellent !
Là on commence à être pas bien
c'est vrai ou pas ?
68632938484
68632938484 *fait entrée*
*tourne en rond et fait le signe d'un pistolet piou piou* YEEEEAH
461881316211
Pour moi  jusqu'ici tout le monde y arrive
c'est à partir de maintenant
c'est le treizième chiffre qui va prendre ton cerveau
et lui mettre des petits coups de *bam bam bam*
dooooonc on va inspirer un grand coup
et bonne chance à tous
1123048849680
112304884928
*cri aigu* je l'ai pas fait je me suis emmêler les pinceaux
ma limite a été atteinte
OK ça c'est fait
Le temps de réaction
haaaanfff mec
mec là je suis malade , je suis fatigué de ouf mon gars , mon temps de réaction
il est scandaleux quoi
je pense que j'ai pas le droit de conduire tellement mon temps de réaction est lent là
quand la couleur passe au vert, clique aussi vite que tu peux
aaaah                 okay    c'est parti !
*concentration maximum*
pfffffffffffffff 255 ms mon gars
quand t'as ça sur un jeu vidéo t'es tellement deg
en faite j'ai l'impression ça se trouve c'est pas mauvais mais naaaan
si je pense c'est mauvais parce qu'1/4 de seconde c'est quand même bien de la merde
je suis pas parti au quart de tour , je suis parti au quart de seconde (.....)
nan sur ce....*malaise*
malade, il tente de faire une blague et c'est le bide.. incroyable
allez, deuxième essai
pfiouuu je vais faire mieux
*lève les bras en l'air* c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien on fait de mieux en mieux c'est bien pppfoooouuuu
allez on se concentre
AAAAAH-ah putain ! ah je régresseuuuh
oooooooooh on est bien
c'est dur - attend là je vais faire un truc de ouf
AH putain, je suis dans le top 91% pour le temps de réaction
Retenir des verbes mais ça va être des verbes en anglais
bon moi je suis bilingue ça me dérange pas
mais pour vous *rigole* gniark gniark excellent la blague
le mec qui se croit bilingue c'est très très beau
allez c'est parti
si tu as vu l'un de ces mots pendant le test appuie sur vu
si c'est un nouveau mot, appuie sur "new"
ok
mais je ? mais il est où le test fin là j'ai tout de suite le mot
je sais pas si je l'ai vu mais c'est quoi ça ? c'est des mots qui sont où je comprends pas
AAAAH ok j'ai compris, putain je suis con ok
en faite là ils vont envoyer pleins de mots et les mots qu'on vient de voir avant "objective"
ils vont revenir plus tard en faite et là du coup il faudra cliquer sur "seen"
et pas sur "new" ok
"sonless" bah c'est nouveau,"lousier" c'est nouveau, "shimmy" c'est nouveau, "lousier" on l'a déjà vu
"spadices" on l'a pas vu, "lousier" roh ça va laissez nous
"sonless" on l'a vu , "itemizers" on l'a pas vu, "shimmy" on l'a vu, "sonless" arrêtez !
"interleaves" on l'a pas vu, "objectives" on l'a vu c'était le premier
"napalm" anh putain niquel c'est une sorte de message codé que le site m'envoie
en mode "eh t'enflamme pas fdp"
"pumpernickel" c'est le mec qui pompe bien c'est le pumpernickel, excellent
"japingly" j'ai vu parce qu'il y japon, "obeyable" j'ai vu, "niches"  j'ai pas vu
nichon, j'ai vu *il est content* POOOOOOOOH
c'est officiellement un beauf , ça y est - qui me remet le diplôme ?
s'il vous plaît
69 points, alors c'est quoi la moyenne
je suis dans les 87% pour ce test ok
mémoire visuelle c'est le jeu du -- c'est parti
là on va pas se mytho au jeu du -- on va tout donner c'est parti
ok
les trois qu'il y a là
y va avoir de plus en plus de carrés c'est trop cool hahaha
c'est trop bien j'aime trop y a un truc dans World of Warcraft où c'est ça faut retenir
la séquence et la refaire j'aime bien ça me fait beaucoup rire
wow, 1 2 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 putain c'est chaud là
3 3
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur
c'est ouf comment mon cerveau relâche petit à petit  c'est un truc de ouf
3 1 ok  1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1  NAAAAAN j'ai perduuuuuuuuuuu
EH mec là j'arrive plus à la fin mon cerveau était trop mauvais
je sais plus
mec là je suis trop mort là j'arrive plus
donc on saura qu'à environ 15 minutes de tournage de vidéo mon cerveau il est vraiment comme ça
*fait une croix avec ses bras* "nope, je ne te suis plus Lucas"
bon alors du coup le score total c'est quoi ?
76 eh bien je ne sais pas si c'est bien ou pas
mais je vous invite à essayer de faire mieux  hein
ça devrait pas être dur *bip*
eh bien les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plû
suite à ces quatre épreuves j'ai obtenu un benchmark de ............
76% voilà
je vous invite à essayer de me battre, ça ne doit pas être très dur vu que j'ai essayé qu'une seule fois
chaque test et qu'en plus j'étais ultra nul au tout dernier, je cherche des excuses oui
nan en vrai n'hésitez pas à le faire , y a un autre site comme ça
je crois c'est "www.mon-qi.com" un truc comme ça, du genre où c'est que des épreuves qui testent un peu ton cerveau
et en faite plus tu les fait et plus ça entraîne ton cerveau et je trouve ça cool de se muscler le cerveau en faite
voilà pour l’anecdote , je vous dit à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé
désolé aujourd'hui c'était pas la grande forme c'était vraiment la maladie, le ganglion qui est là
qui fait vraiment la taille de ce pot de gel acheté en corée
tu sais- vraiment j'ai ça dans la gorge mec c'est très désagréable
allez merci d'avoir regardé je vous dit à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
je m'en vais dormir -- ALLEZ AU REVOIR